this is not because i don't enjoy
lecturing i love lecturing and i get a
great deal out of the experience and i
see my role in lecturing to enthuse
students but in terms of active learning
just sitting there for 50 minutes for
one thing why 50 minutes
why why do we stuff people in here for
an hour or you know 50 minutes to an
hour why that quantum of time
all right professor where are you
standing at the moment where are we i'm
standing in the largest lecture theater
in the physics building and actually one
of the largest lecture theaters at the
university of nottingham what we're
going to talk about today is the death
of the lecture we're in the midst of a
pandemic and higher education and
lecturing is going to be changed or is
in the process of being changed
dramatically there's a wonderful quote
from virginia woolf university lectures
are an obsolete practice inherited from
the middle ages when books were scarce
to swallow instruction from a lectern is
like sipping through a straw lectures
pander to the vanity of the lecturer do
you agree with that i do i agree
entirely with that
are lectures dead should they be dead
no definitely not i guess it's been
given a particular currency because of
lockdown and the fact that we haven't
actually been able to give lectures and
the fact that we actually finished up
our teaching for this academic year
online but actually the discussion's
been going on a lot longer than that and
what's really precipitated it
was the
prevalence of lecture capture the fact
that lecture capture is happening that
we're basically videoing and recording
all our lectures are making them
available to students and so then the
obvious question you ask is well what
was the point in being at the lecture
you know why don't i just listen to the
lecture capture
and
certainly my view is that they are not
in any way interchangeable i think it is
ridiculous that a process whereby we
just stuff students into our lecture
theater and talk at them we've been
doing that for centuries and it's really
easy
it's really easy for a lecturer just to
stand up here and talk particularly if
all you're doing is effectively taking
notes from a book firing them out and
expecting the the students to absorb
that by osmosis how do you really deeply
learn something do you sit and just
watch somebody talk at you and listen to
it
or do you actively engage with it so for
example at the moment what i'm trying to
do
is use is try to do something called
triplets on drums which is basically da
da da da da da just three drums in a row
now i can watch as many
videos as i like
explaining this is how you do triplets
or what a triplet is i'm not going to
get any further in terms of engaging
with that material or any musical
instrument anything you can think of in
terms of how do you learn to play an
instrument
you practice you engage with the
material and you do something active so
you burn it into your neurons that's not
what's happening in a lecture if you go
to elect you know if it's a nine o'clock
lecture you've made a particular effort
to be there you've kind of you know
committed to going there you're sitting
there for an hour there are no other
distractions you're surrounded by a
whole bunch of other students who are
all focused on what's going on in the
lecture so i actually you know it really
kind of is going to be a completely
different experience from
watching a youtube video while you're
doing three other things at the same
time making yourself a cheese toasty
and chatting to your mates you talk
about the fact that students at a
lecture pay attention more do they pay
attention though are they just turning
up because they have to be ticked off a
list i i mean they don't have to be
there right and you know nothing bad
happens to them if they don't turn up i
mean we'll ask why they weren't there
but actually you know we don't kick them
out of the university or anything like
that it really is you know you just want
a little bit of pressure to get people
to go to the lecture then they bother to
attend and they get all the benefits
that come from actually being in the
lecture there's a wonderful lecture in
harvard a physicist called eric missouri
he's got this wonderful quote which is
the traditional lecture involves
transferring the notes from the notebook
of the lecturer to the notebooks of the
students without going through the
brains of either
and that might be overstating the case a
little bit but it's not overstating the
case a lot and again i see my role
really about enthusiasm it's about
getting the students to say well this is
interesting
what you know this is a really
interesting subject i want to find out
more about this i want to do the
coursework because the subject is
interesting i want to understand this
more but the intellectual heavy lifting
doesn't come from me or shouldn't come
from me
it comes from the students and that's
not what's happening in this type of
environment it's really important when
you're learning that there's a
reasonable amount of structure imposed
on what you're doing that you're
learning things in the right order that
you're learning them from the right
resources in a consistent way that
everything sort of fits together with
everything else
and the nice thing about the structure
of a lecture is that that's sort of
built into it right that actually the
lecture has all that has that flow to it
it's sort of done in a very sort of
consistent way whereas if you're just
dipping into you know this resource and
that resource it's very hard to get that
kind of structured learning which is an
important part of the the learning
process making sure that students focus
within this environment and that there's
something to get you know i've got a
nine o'clock lecture i'll get up for it
i won't get offered but at least the
structure there that is important but to
me it seems like a real cop-out to say
that well all we're doing is structuring
the material we can do so much more with
that 50 minutes rather than just have
the traditional lecture we have some
levels of interaction you know we have
we give the students these little
clickers that allow them to answer
questions during the course of the
lecture so there is sort of even in a
large lecture with 200 students in it i
am getting that feedback did that thing
i just explained go across right or have
i failed to explain it miserably in
which case they're not going to be able
to answer this simple you know multiple
choice question i've just asked them so
there are lots of places where there is
interaction even in the conventional
lecture so the lecture in its current
format i would say
we really do anything to need to think
about the death of that but of course
we're not going to throw the baby out
with the bath water so what we will do
and i think it's sort of obvious
the grand term that's being used is
chunking which seems
really strange because you've been
chunking for years brady you've been
breaking material up into five and ten
minute videos that's what we should do
short 5 10 minutes 60 symbols like
videos on a particular topic accompanied
with um for example a simulation a piece
of javascript or whatever that that
codes some of that
with parameters and that can be adjusted
and changed so that students can
effectively do a numerical experiment
and say well if he's talking about this
about just these sliders what happens
and that interactivity is important
again in terms of getting the concepts
and then we use the lecture slots
whatever lecture slots we have is
available as problems classes and as
discussion groups and i'll set up some
here are some problems and what we're
going to do is we're going to discuss
those problems now you could say well
what if the students don't do the
problems well what we do is we have some
credit associated we have some marks
associated with the coursework to
encourage them gently to do the work and
to engage with the work that's what i'd
like there is this thing called the
flipped classroom which is the idea is
that basically in the classroom instead
of the lecturer standing up and teaching
things the students have pre-read a
bunch of stuff
and then basically you get them to solve
problems in the class you get them to
interact with you to interact with each
other and get much more of a dialogue
going it's a nice idea in principle it
clearly works to a degree but actually
there is interesting evidence that
suggests it's not quite the golden
bullet that some people have been
arguing that it is there was a test done
last year
by some researchers at mit where they
did the controlled experiment of some
people being taught in a flipped
classroom way some people were being
taught in a conventional way they found
that the overall attainment was about
the same in both groups but actually the
flipped classroom group the spread of
attainment was much bigger in that the
better students really enjoyed it and
got a lot out of it and did better but
the weaker students really struggled
with it and for example students from
minority groups found it very hard and
in retrospect i think there are kind of
obvious reasons for that right that
actually you would expect that if you're
a slightly disenfranchised group if you
come up with a way of teaching that
really requires you to interact
effectively with the other students
then you're going to find it harder to
do if you're they're not your natural
social peer group that you've been
interacting with anyway so i think you
know part of the argument against the
traditional lecture is that there are
newer better ways of doing it i would
just caution that those newer better
ways sometimes have some some
shortcomings of their own this comes
home to me i've had tutorial groups
what's absolutely clear that one of the
students in that group is absolutely
uncomfortable with being in that small
group
and being sort of on the edge of their
seat maybe i'm going to get asked a
question and i don't know this and
what are the others going to think of me
so what we have to do is just
recognize that there are different ways
of learning other students for example
in a tutorial group are rushing to the
board to do things
but some aren't so we have to have a
blended approach to learning it's sort
of obvious in some ways
but again just stuffing lots of people
in here and talking at them is not the
way to do it i've heard you're a good
lecturer do you not do you not think
they've added something unique to
people's university experience into
their education sitting in your lectures
if i've enthused people yes but i want
them to come away from this not going
well i listen to that that was amazing
i've learned a lot
i want them to come away with it going
i've listened to that that was really
amazing and interesting and you know he
was very enthusiastic about it i want to
learn more
that's the key thing and lecture is
exciting
depends on the lecturer
it's interesting right some of my
colleagues you know sometimes they end
up with what looked like deadly dull
subjects to lecture
but they find exciting ways to present
them others sometimes look like they've
got the most exciting optional thing
that will you know tell people about
cutting-edge research in some area or
other and they managed to sound it make
it sound deadly dull
so
it is a bit varied i just don't think
you improve that situation dramatically
by just changing the medium you're using
for teaching phil i know that you really
love music
uh your best music experience the times
when you've listened to songs at home on
your own chunks of music
and things like that or have that has it
been when you've been at concerts with
thousands of other people seeing them in
the flesh brilliant absolutely brilliant
point brady yes that collective communal
experience whatever is very very
important and that interaction between
the students is very important i am not
suggesting that we get rid of that i'm
suggesting that what we do is we amplify
that get them talking to each other
during the the lectures get them arguing
with me it's a final year module i do
called the politics perception and
philosophy of physics which i think i've
mentioned before the first time i did
that because it's quite different it's
more like a humanity set up in that
there are seminars and discussion groups
so i'll talk for 20 minutes and then
open up the floor i expected it to be
tumbleweight these are physicists after
all what
traditional physics
courses you just talk at them but the
floodgates opened and they debated and
they discussed and they argued in a
friendly way and sometimes yeah no
usually in a friendly way and they
argued with me as well and that's what i
want that's what should happen that's so
much better than
me statically sort of giving that that
information out what do you say to
someone who says well mike's the head of
school at a university physics
department of course he's going to
advocate for something that you know you
can only get at a university
um is that true statement i guess that
is a true statement i mean
it's true to an extent
and there are people who are perfectly
you know autodidact's who can go out and
really learn these things on their own
i think probably the learning process
intrinsically requires somebody to be
guiding you through it and whether that
guidance comes from a lecturer standing
at the front of a lecture theater or a
tutor you're chatting with about your
problems trying to to understand a
particular area of the subject
you know
there will be different ways that
guidance is given the lecture is just
one of the ways that guidance is given
education is difficult lecturing is easy
some will disagree but
that's certainly my perspective on this
i'm sure i hope this will generate some
debate down there i hope the comments
section will light up but i would argue
that lecturing is easy education is
difficult for example we lecturers have
a much easier job than secondary school
teachers high school teachers much
easier job
what about the heritage einstein gave
lectures this is a wonderful thing
that's happened for so many years and
now you want to have zoom calls and
quizzes einstein didn't have an iphone
so
einstein didn't um communicate with
people on the other side of the world
almost instantaneously einstein
lived in a different world
and the physicists who einstein was
teaching and the physicists that who
were interacting with einstein it was a
very different time and the skills that
you needed then are very different from
the skills you need today
having made the case for lectures and
talking about how valuable you think
they are to education
we're recording this during a pandemic
where it looks like you're not going to
be able to give them for who knows how
long how catastrophic is that the
process has been non-stop in that we
moved all of our teaching very rapidly
online in a very ad hoc fashion when it
all started we then got into assessment
how do we do exams we figured out ways
of doing that we've just completed the
assessment we've just been returning the
students their marks the next thing on
the list is okay so that's done now how
do we teach it better next year so we're
already i was in a
skype meeting yesterday where we were
discussing new methods for teaching what
technology we're going to use what
approaches we're going to use how we're
going to split things up into smaller
pieces how we're going to ensure that
there are you know q and a sessions with
lecturers and ways for them to engage
with the lecturer
we're only working our way through that
now
hopefully you know this is not the long
term where we're going to be forever and
so we're trying to develop things in a
way that's sort of blended that allows
us to combine face-to-face things with
online things so that we can shift the
balance as times allow
but we're really just feeling our way
through it at the moment
would anything be lost by the death of
the lecture
no i don't think in the death of the
traditional lecture format no i do i
don't think we will have the same
elements
um we will have the ability to have a
lecturer who's
there is hopefully engaging is hopefully
explaining the material but in a much
more
interactive way in terms of being led by
the students
rather than just going well i'll prepare
my lecture notes the night before and
just dump them at the students who's
going to win this we're already seeing
some universities saying oh we're going
to go online next year and things like
that are you going to end up being right
here
i think that in terms of how we modify
the lectures yes i would say it's not
just i've got to point out it's not just
me there are many other people who think
along these lines i think yes we're
going to see a change and i think the
important thing is is stuff that would
have you know two years ago would have
said if i want to do things this way the
argument would have been well just we
don't have the resources to do that
there's no way we can do that it's
really interesting how this pandemic has
focused the mind and things that would
have previously been absolutely beyond
the pale suddenly are within reach with
this current pandemic i think coming out
the other side of it enduring it we've
got an opportunity really to radically
change things and i would be so
disappointed
if we come out the other side of this
and all that happens is well i got a
slightly higher resolution camera to
fill my traditional lectures that would
be so disappointing
if you'd like to see both of the
full-length interviews that went into
this video i'm going to put the links on
the screen and down in the video
description i also think there's like a
little bit of star power in a strange
way to being taught in person by a
person who does the thing and knows the
stuff even if it's a lowly astronomer
being talked being taught astronomy by
someone who's been there and done it and
done real astronomy and written papers
and used the big telescopes has like a
kind of a
a star quality if you excuse the pun and
also it means that you know when they
come up with questions at the end that
weren't on the syllabus hopefully it
means the lecturer can actually answer
them because you know they actually know
the subject they don't just know the
thing that they're teaching they don't
just know the syllabus they're teaching
they actually know the subject around it
you can see plenty more videos too with
mike and phil both on 60 symbols and
deep sky videos i'm going to include
links to those as well